this video is brought to you by
squarespace the best way to make an
amazing website
when i first got the iphone 12 mini into
my hands i was intrigued
it was incredibly small and lightweight
yet at the same time
really premium so i was really excited
to test it out and see if i can finally
swap over to a smaller phone
unfortunately after two months i can't
really recommend this phone for most
people
and there's more than a few reasons to
spend that little bit more
and get the iphone 12 or maybe hold off
altogether and wait for the iphone 13
mini
if apple even makes one which we'll talk
about with that said
there are so many things that i
absolutely love about this phone
and reasons that i want to keep using it
but there's also
a few issues that i've experienced one
of them being
so massive that is just not worth me
using anymore
even if i do love the size and weight
let's start out with the best thing
about the iphone 12 mini
and that is the size now i knew it was
going to be small but you really don't
understand
what it's like unless you get to hold it
in your hand and of course if you have
maybe say an
iphone 5 or 5s now i'm used to using
large phones but even then i was just
tempted to keep using it so if you're
somebody that has an older iphone and
you love the size
the iphone 12 mini is actually smaller
and lighter than the 4.7 inch iphones
including the new se
while at the same time the display is a
fair bit larger as well
for those of you that are coming from
one of those iphone 5s the 12 mini
is just slightly larger and heavier but
of course its design
now has circled back to the square
chassis and it's actually slightly
thinner
as well so if you like how your old
phones feel you will love this one
comfort wise comparing it to the iphone
12 yeah
it is definitely more comfortable side
by side but most people will get used to
that larger size
and then they'll have no issues with it
now there's one huge advantage that the
mini has
over the other 12 models in terms of its
size
and that is that it is perfect for
apple's magsafe wallet i've tested the
wallet on all of the new iphone 12s and
by far the best phone for the wallet
is the mini now a lot of reviewers
tested the wallet and they complained
about it
that's because it just doesn't work very
well on other phones especially with
iphone 12 pro max
it constantly twists and slides around
unable to stay secure on the phone
but with the mini on the other hand the
wallet held very well
since the sides and bottom match up
perfectly so never twist off center
not only that but it also feels super
comfortable to hold with the wallet
unlike on the 12 pro max where it feels
kind of weird because of the extra gaps
on the sides
now let's talk about that really nice
full screen display the mini has that
5.4 inches which is a really nice
upgrade from the older 4.7
to maybe 4 inch iphones so not only are
you getting a smaller phone compared to
the 4.7
but also a more efficient one getting a
full screen display that doesn't weigh
space with huge bezels
now along with that the mini actually
has apple's most detailed display
because the display is smaller than the
other 12s its pixels are just more
packed together
which results in the mini having 476 ppi
while the 12 pro max has 458 and in case
you're curious the iphone sc has 326
now considering the small display
compared to the other 12s
it's a common worry that you wouldn't
have as much screen real estate as on
the larger phones
when you're watching websites or reading
things like that
but honestly that wasn't an issue for
optimized websites
you can see almost just as much as you
can on the 12 pro max
everything is just a little bit smaller
now before i get into the two issues
that i have
with the display specifically let me
give a shout out to the sponsor of this
video
squarespace if you've been thinking
about making your own website
squarespace is seriously the best way to
go
we've built multiple websites and you
can too with literally no web making
experience
you just choose a template customize
blocks of text and images and easily
move them around
it's incredibly simple affordable and rs
have been running flawlessly for years
now
bringing in new clients thanks to its
built-in seo tools so whether you're
making a website for a small business or
for
literally anything else go to
squarespace.comtech for a free trial
or use our custom link down below and
when you're ready to launch you will
save 10 off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain one issue that i've been dealing
with is
constantly making typos since the phone
screen is so small
and my fingers are so big and the other
issue with the display being so small
is that gaming on this phone is very
difficult and kind of annoying
it's a lot harder to see because
everything is so small and not only that
but my fingers take up
so much room on that display let's just
say that the iphone 12
is much better for gaming and typing but
of course
if you're used to a small phone already
that shouldn't be an issue now one thing
that really surprised me
with this phone is its performance in
thermals when i really pushed it
it never got hot like the max did on the
max
after about a half hour of gaming at
full settings it would overheat and then
the screen
would turn down and then would lock into
about
half brightness to until it cools down
but
surprisingly that never once happened on
the mini and that performance is thanks
to the insanely powerful
5 nanometer a14 the cpu and graphics
performance is
absolutely crazy and it's the same exact
on the mini
as on that 12 pro max the only slight
difference in performance
is ram with the mini having four
gigabytes instead of six
but to be honest i didn't really notice
a difference maybe that's because ios
is just a lot more efficient with latest
versions or maybe because i just didn't
end up using my iphone 12 as much
as i would with the larger ones which
could be a good thing for some of you
one reason for that is because the
screen is quite small but the other
reason
are the speakers they are great now i
wasn't expecting them to sound as good
as the 12 pro max but i didn't think
they would be the same as the iphone se
and a fair bit worse than the iphone 12.
not only does the quality sound worse in
general but it's also
quieter the mids are really lacking and
the bass is pretty much non-existent
have a listen for yourself
[Music]
now i know for some of you this won't
matter but the two biggest things that i
do on my phone
is write messages and emails and then
watch youtube videos
so since the screen is smaller and the
speakers are a lot weaker i just found
myself using it much
less and i would go and grab a laptop or
an ipad
with that said that's not what really
messed up my experience with it and the
battery life didn't either
that was a huge worry for me and many
others before i got this phone
but i was pleasantly surprised based on
my real world use with 5g enabled
i expected the battery to be dead by 3
pm but every day
ended up lasting until 5 or even 6 pm
and i do push my phones
fairly hard the iphone 12 would
typically die at six to seven pm so it
only lasted about an hour more than this
one
and comparing to my 12 pro max well that
thing lasted all day
up until 10 or 11 pm so the mini can't
really match up there
but that also has a 60 larger battery
and if you're somebody with an iphone se
you'll get about one to two more hours
of screen on time with the mini
and the same thing goes with older
iphones that have older worn out
batteries
it's gonna be a good improvement for you
now to be honest this makes no
difference for me
because if i have to top off during the
day it doesn't matter if it's an hour
earlier or later
so if you're worried about battery life
honestly don't be
and the same thing goes for camera
quality thankfully apple didn't cheap
out and even though the 12 mini cost 100
less than the 12 we still have dual rear
cameras and the same exact front facing
one that also means that the quality is
exactly the same as a 12
pro other than not having that zoom
camera but honestly
an ultron camera is much more useful and
for the most part
you're not missing much photo quality
went up dramatically this year with
nighttime photos being possible with the
front-facing camera
which makes shots go from being dark or
ugly to nice looking shots
and ultrawide photos went from a blurry
mess to some amazing looking images
if you want to see the few details
between the camera systems on the 12
mini
the 12 12 pro and the high-end 12-pro
max model i actually did a very in-depth
camera comparison showing every single
camera difference
which you can watch after this video
i'll leave a link down below now i want
to finally get into
the big deal breaker about this phone
that caused me enough frustration
that i could no longer deal with it and
i need to use
one of the larger phones and that is
connection speed
and reception speeds got a huge boost
this year with the 12s compared to the
11s
thanks to apple using the super fast
snapdragon x55 modem with 5g
for example outside of my church the
place where i struggled the most with
reception
i would get about 6 mb per second
download and 0.3
upload on my 11 pro max now testing the
speeds on the regular 12 and the 12 pro
which have the same exact setup i would
get 38 megabit per second download and
two megabit per second upload
that is over six times faster now inside
of my church i would get no service
at all with the 11 pro but i would
actually get one to two bars with the
iphone 12s
however with the 12 mini this isn't the
case
i get zero service inside the building
nothing and that is extremely
frustrating
and outside it is still a fair bit
slower than the iphone 12.
now i'm not sure why this is because
they're very similar but i did go back
and forth a few times
and it definitely is caused by this
phone overall
this has been noticeable in multiple
places across town which is a huge deal
breaker for me
because i need to have service now last
year with the iphone 11 there was
nothing i could do
and i was stuck with what i had but this
year knowing that the 12 and 12 pros
and then the 12 pro max can give me
service in places where i previously
didn't have it
there's just no way that i could stick
to using the mini so even though
i love the size because of those reasons
i have a hard time recommending this
unless you absolutely have to have the
smallest size
and in those cases it really seems like
not many people
actually do you see people have been
asking for a smaller phone
like the iphone 5 for years now but
nobody really thought
or expected apple to listen and deliver
when apple updated the se to the gen
2 with the updated a13 chip it was a big
surprise and people were happy
however not that much changed other than
that chip
and people wanted to get a bigger
upgrade i think that apple took a huge
risk
making this phone and while people were
asking for it
not nearly as many people actually ended
up buying one
if you look around at sales the iphone
12 lineup accounted for about 76 percent
of iphones
sold during october and november which
is better than the levins did last year
with the regular 12s making up about 27
so most of that portion both the iphone
12 pro and the pro max each sold about
percent however the twelve mini only
accounted for
six percent of total sales which was
shockingly low to me
because it's the first time the apple is
offering such a small phone
for all those people that are asking it
while keeping the performance
and the camera the same as iphone 12 and
dropping the price by 100 bucks
my only guess is that most people
thought that the regular 12 was a better
buy even if it costs more
and after the last two months i would
definitely agree and i actually wonder
if apple will ever make an
iphone 13 mini or they're just gonna
keep selling this one for multiple years
as they have done with the ses
now despite all of that the 12 mini is
still a nice phone and i would recommend
it if you
really need a tiny one but i think that
most people should just go for an iphone
12
instead but you guys go ahead and let me
know what you think down below
this has been max click that circle
above to help us reach our goal of 600k
subs
before march which is our two year mark
that would be absolutely amazing
check out one of those great videos
right over there and i will see you in
the next one